blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman one of the biggest impediments to
getting things done
in the united states senate when you
have a majority
but not a 60-seat majority is to
filibuster and the filibuster is a
mechanism through which
even if you only need 50 votes to pass
something you need 60 votes to
end debate on that very issue
and move to the vote and this is a
mechanism that allows
a party in the minority to indefinitely
hold up
voting on legislation and to obstruct
and to do all of the things that
republicans led by mitch mcconnell
love to do to democrats now democrats
could blow up the filibuster completely
this is called the nuclear option and
we've talked about it before
but it is a double-edged sword and it
could as i've
talked to you before about it could come
back to really bite democrats when
republicans are back
in the majority at some point in the
future this has been a point of
contention about which there are
reasonable positions on both sides
but in an interview with abc news that
aired last night
joe biden told george stephanopoulos he
does
support reforming the senate filibuster
not eliminating it with the nuclear
option but reforming it well what
exactly is the reform that joe biden
is interested in let's take a look at
the clip zach so aren't you going to
have to choose
i know you've been reluctant to do away
with the filibuster aren't you gonna
have to choose
between preserving the filibuster and
advancing your agenda
yes but here's the choice i don't think
you have to eliminate the filibuster you
have to
do it what it used to be when i first
got to the senate back in the old days
when you used to be around there and
that is that a filibuster you had to
stand up and command the floor
and you had to keep talking alone you
couldn't call for you know
they no one could say you know quorum
call
once you stop talking you lost that and
someone could move in and say
i moved the question of so you got to
work for the filibuster
so you're for that reform you're for
bringing back the talking filibuster i
am
that's what it was supposed to be look i
think don't hold me to the numbers
george but i think
between 1960 and 2000 they were like i'm
making this number up i don't know
there were like uh you know 50
filibusters now they're like 200 since
then
since then just put a hold on it that's
it yeah i mean you know so
the idea it almost is getting to the
point where
there's you know democracy's having a
hard time functioning
a hard time functioning now this is
notable for a few reasons now
just a couple of days ago joe biden's
press secretary jenn saki was asked
about the filibuster during a press
briefing
and she said joe biden does not want to
change any rules on the filibuster
so that seems to have changed but more
importantly on substance
biden doesn't say get rid of the
filibuster
just make it more difficult by requiring
an actual talking filibuster and
this is an important detail to
understand right now
senators can indefinitely extend debate
on a topic
and prevent voting on that topic by
asking
to extend debate period and just never
allowing debate to end
when someone moves to end debate and
vote republicans can say no i want to
extend debate and they're able to do it
in the past senators actually had to
hold the floor
and speak and keep speaking to delay a
bill
and the idea that joe biden is
suggesting and others have also
mentioned
is to require the actual speaking to
take place so senators can't just
ask for an extension and then another
one and then another one
they actually have to talk through the
filibuster and this would have two
effects
first of all it would require
republicans to actually
organize to have back to back-to-back
speakers in the senate
never-ending with their 50 senators they
actually
would be able to do it but how long will
they be willing to do it from a
practical standpoint
24 7 day after day after day
but maybe more importantly a talking
filibuster
that goes on and on and on merely to
prevent a vote
on an issue is going to pick up media
attention the longer it goes
and presumably it will come off as
exactly the type of blatant obstruction
that it is
now the possible political
miscalculation
is that we're assuming the current
republican party
would be mad about that and they would
say this must end let's just have a vote
but the current republican party has
been so propagandized
that they might not actually be that mad
about an endless talking filibuster they
might like it but the gamble
is that the left and the centrists and
maybe some republicans would say guys we
we don't have control of the senate this
isn't really democratic
this has to end you have to put the
issue to a vote maybe that is what
what would happen i don't know now why
does this matter bigger picture
it matters because filibuster rules
in the next two years might actually
determine
does washington dc become a state does
puerto rico become a state
does automatic voter registration get
passed
and a whole bunch of other important
issues this is not trivial and the point
is that right now
it's too easy to filibuster with very
little work and without much political
cost
now there's a couple of other ideas that
have been floated one i this this is not
what biden supports but these are other
ideas
to affect the filibuster without ending
it
one idea is you have to have 40
senators present to extend the
filibuster right now
it's if you don't have 60
you can't end debate the idea is to
flip the onus and put it on republicans
to keep having 40 of their 50 senators
in the chamber 24 7 to continue
extending the filibuster
that would be a very good idea without
blowing it up
the other thing is that the talking
filibuster
it should have to be relevant to the
topic at hand in other words
if you are trying to end debate on
automatic voter registration
and go to a vote you can't get up there
and read a dr seuss book to filibuster
you should be filibustering materially
with something connected to automatic
voter registration
and that's another possibility that
could be done we will see
this is a really big deal and you know
it's one of these things where
a lot of this stuff like oh joe when is
joe biden going to do his first press
conference
sort of like you know it's an inside the
beltway
story that also has very little impact
on americans
the filibuster is something a lot of
people are not following
and aren't aware of but it actually does
relate
to things that would have a very direct
and serious impact
uh on on americans in terms of what it
would allow the senate to do so we're
going to continue following now
this is this is joe biden's latest view
on this issue
let's now talk about the flip side of
the coin which is
mitch mcconnell's view on the issue so
we heard from joe biden yesterday he's
not for abolishing the filibuster but he
wants to modify it and require
an actual talking filibuster on the
other side of this is now senate
minority leader
mitch mcconnell republican from kentucky
and
he is now very strongly threatening
to obstruct everything democrats want to
do
unless he is allowed to continue
obstructing in the way that he has been
able to do
i i know that that sounds crazy but what
you have to understand is
mitch mcconnell's going to obstruct
either way mitch mcconnell is now
warning democrats that if they try to
mess with the filibuster
he will use procedural delays to turn
the senate into a
quote 100 car pileup
saying quote nobody serving in this
chamber can
even begin to imagine what a complete
scorched earth senate would look like
i want our colleagues to imagine a world
where every single task
every one of them requires a physical
quorum
which by the way the vice president does
not count in determining a quorum
and many democrats are realizing
he's already been just obstructing at
every opportunity for years dick durbin
saying he's already done that
he's proven they that he can do it and
that they will do it again
i assume mitch mcconnell has to be
ignored now i'm not denying for a second
that certainly mitch mcconnell if
democrats either try to abolish the
filibuster which it doesn't seem like
they're going to do
or modify it requiring a talking
filibuster reversing the onus
on 40 60 as i talked about earlier
whatever they try to do
i have no doubt mitch mcconnell will do
and will be able to do
certain things to obstruct but mitch
mcconnell has been doing that anyway
mitch mcconnell is like an arsonist
threatening to burn down your house
when he already burned it down a week
ago and you're already living somewhere
else
and mitch mcconnell uh in the past when
harry reid
10 years ago he forced harry reid uh
to to have to go nuclear to get anything
done
and he obstructed with the merrick
garland selection by barack obama at the
end of barack obama's term saying we
don't do
supreme court picks in the last year of
a term and then he rushed amy coney
barrett through in two weeks
he will obstruct when it's convenient at
any time he has no morals he has no
principles
he will take whatever steps he wants and
thinks will be beneficial to republicans
at the time and then he will rationalize
it
regardless of double standard regardless
of consistency
i don't think democrats have any choice
but to ignore him and what i mean by
that is
if you do nothing then they obstruct as
a matter of procedure
if you do something then they retaliate
by obstructing he's painting this
hellscape
as talking points memo uh defines it
that as soon as they take back the
majority
they go back to running everything
through and ignoring democrats
how long are democrats going to pay
attention to the threats from mitch
mcconnell
and as propagandized and weaponized as
as the ignorance is on the republican
side right now
i do believe that it will start to have
some consequences
if mitch mcconnell uh does what he's
threatening to do
so what democrats should do is just
listen if they're not going to blow up
the filibuster and i understand the
risks to doing so
i i get it i it's not clear to me that
it's the right path
at least agree on what reforms you want
maybe you change it to require a talking
filibuster
maybe you change it to require 40
republicans in the chamber
to extend debate rather than just an
absence of 60 being enough
to extend debate you figure out what
you're going to do and then you just do
it
and you allow mitch mcconnell to deal
with the consequences
of continuing to obstruct many
republicans won't care i get that
but i believe that some will and
combined with centrist independents and
and democrats and leftists uh i think it
will be enough to damage the republican
party that's my view now if you disagree
with me if you think it will have no
consequences
and you actually have to listen to mitch
mcconnell here and take the threat
seriously in terms of how it would
affect what democrats do on the
filibuster
let me know i want to hear from you i'm
on twitter at deepakman
and then reminder friday not this friday
next friday march 26th
we are running an end of march one day
membership special it is going to be a
huge discount it's because we had a
really rough
february the virus the pandemic
affecting people financially
i got dozens and dozens of emails from
people saying david i love the show
been a member for years i've got to cut
every bell whistle and extra from my
budget i get that
so we're going to offer a really big
discount on march 26th i would love for
you to sign up if you're interested
it's almost like pre-registering for the
vaccine actually
get on my newsletter at davidpakman.com
and then friday you'll get an email
telling you exactly how to sign up
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and
a subscription is only about eight bucks
a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
percent off a subscription when you go
to
slash blinkist.com pakman i've put the
link right underneath this video
remember that our show is funded mostly
by viewers and listeners
just like you who sign up at
joinpacman.com
grab a membership coupon code available
but never mandatory
better 21 saves you a bundle
all right let's get right into former
president donald trump's
came out swinging interview yesterday
donald trump gave a painfully deranged
and comically delusional interview
with fox news propagandist maria
bartoromo
last night one of the top brown nosers
of the right-wing media apparatus
is maria bartoromo among other things
donald trump claimed that he quote came
up with
uh the coronavirus vaccine um take a
look at this
you add the fact that i was the one and
this administration was the one that
came up with a vaccine
which is going to save the world okay
it's going to save we would be
i think worse than 1917 where
50 to 100 million people died the
vaccine is such a big thing
when you add it all up i think we'll do
very well in
two years and i think we're going to do
very well in four years trump still
calling the 1918 flu pandemic the 1917
pandemic we still don't know why he's
doing that but he continues to do that
but more importantly more more comically
donald trump insisting that he came up
with the covet vaccine
that he said we didn't really need to
get out of a pandemic that wasn't very
serious
a vaccine he received in private in
january and kept secret until it leaked
about 10 days ago that he had received
that's the vaccine he says he came up
with
completely disconnected from reality and
remember that
this is the guy who asked that the start
of kovid
if the flu shot would prevent
coronavirus
that's not a joke remember this but the
same vaccine could not work you take
a solid flu vaccine you don't think that
would have an impact or much of an
impact on corona
no no probably not
probably not
um also on the vaccine trump recommends
it although he says freedoms are still
important so good i mean he's
recommending it i think that that's a
good thing
this has been a bigger issue over the
last few days democrats
and health officials saying trump should
really tell his followers to get the
vaccine
they are one of the most anti-coveted
vaccine groups
and trump was prompted on this issue and
he said i do recommend it but you know
we've got to pay attention to freedoms
too mr president i know that you
received the vaccine mrs trump also got
the vaccine would you recommend
to our audience that they get the
vaccine then
i would i would recommend it and i would
recommend it to
a lot of people that don't want to get
it and a lot of those people voted for
me frankly but
you know i again we have our freedoms
and we have to
live by that and i agree with that also
so listen i'm not even going to dig into
that let's just leave it at
trump said he recommends it all the
other stuff we'll put aside
it's good that he's recommending the
vaccine to his followers
when the topic of the 2020 election came
up
and actually the the topic of georgia
specifically also came up
donald trump is still repeating now
almost what almost five
months three four and a half almost five
months beyond the election
trump continues to repeat the same lies
about the election and at one point he
gets so worked up
that he actually hits buttons on his
phone while talking
extra bonus in this clip is maria
bartoromo
trying to interrupt trump multiple times
maybe worried that trump is starting to
go
dangerously close to the type of claims
that could put fox
in legal jeopardy as we've seen them
them be and other right-wing media when
this type of stuff is said
uh this just a comedy of errors taking
place here
most honest person it was it was a
beautiful
it was a beautiful and perfect statement
and the washington post saw that when
they heard it
and i guess they were relying on the the
statement without hearing
what was said but they were relying on
the statement made by people in georgia
that run the elections it's a
very terrible thing a very very terrible
thing for our country
what took place in georgia but not only
georgia what took place in pennsylvania
what took place in detroit michigan and
michigan generally
what took place in wisconsin mr
president arizona
uh it is a disgrace it's a we're like a
third world country
and then donald trump quite literally
bemoaning that the supreme court didn't
overturn the election results they
weren't willing to do it
and our supreme court and our courts
didn't have the courage
to overturn elections that should have
been overturned because you're talking
about decisive amounts
hundreds of thousands and even millions
of votes he talks about
the supreme court overturning an
election
like it would be a completely reasonable
and casual
thing to do which of course it wouldn't
donald trump then says that he hopes
meghan markle does run for president
and that that would make him more likely
to have a good shot
at winning he uh on the side of the
queen apparently and reminding us he's
met the queen
your take on megan marco uh now
saying she meeting with democrat
operatives she may want to run for
president
well i hope that happens because uh if
that happened then i'd be
i think i'd have an even stronger
feeling toward running
i'm not a fan of hers i think that what
she
talks about the royal family and the
queen i happen to think i know the queen
as you know i've met with the queen and
i think the queen is a tremendous person
and i am not a fan of megan
yeah so trump is pro queen auntie
meghan markle for those who are
wondering trump then repeating the lie
at least an unfounded claim apparently a
lie
that terrorists from the middle east are
crossing the u.s mexico border
hey uh they're coming in you take a look
they're coming in from all foreign
countries i see they're coming in now
from yemen
they're coming in from the middle east
they're coming in from
everywhere they're dropping them off and
they're they're pouring into our country
now we have an entire segment devoted to
the border and this topic so i'm just
going to say
there is no evidence of what trump is
saying but we'll dig into that in more
detail in a little bit
and then donald trump still repeating
the lie
that barack obama and joe biden did
terribly
on the h1n1 virus years ago
titan failed very badly with the h1n1
with the
as you know uh the the
he had a chance to do something and they
had a tremendous
tremendous failure h1n1 it was a
disaster
now the truth is that um the h1n1 virus
uh was essentially the regular flu in
terms of its severity
and once that was determined it was why
uh once you had community spread and
something that you didn't really treat
any differently than flu a testing was
ramped down they often like to say they
weren't testing h1n1 well
there was no reason to test once you had
community spread
um and uh the actual approval rating for
obama and biden on h1n1 was 67
so by biden actually not failing
and not unpopular on that issue
everything a lie complete and total
and my question is like what do you
think trump wants to gain from these
interviews is it merely that he still
has this
kind of sycophantic narcissistic desire
for uh relevance
and publicity is it that he considers
these interviews to be
um part of his goal of being king maker
going into 2022 what what is the is he
just bored
what is his objective in doing these
interviews i'd love to hear from you
about that
uh this is something you have to see for
weeks now
right wing media has been going bananas
over joe biden not having a press
conference
joe biden has now announced a press
conference for next thursday
and now the problem has become it's
bad that joe biden announced the press
conference
so far in advance this is once again
proof that you can't please these people
and you shouldn't try to please these
people so as a reminder
the day before yesterday on fox big
explosive headline
biden 54 days without a press conference
yesterday on fox joe biden 55 days
without a press conference
a few days ago in the washington post
quoting donald trump's former press
secretary kaylee
mcinanni biden isn't doing press
conferences because he's being protected
by his staff
from unscripted questions last week
fox news reporting on the chicago
tribune op-ed
titled how long can president biden hide
from real news conferences earlier last
week
fox news with a big table with the
number of days
until the fresh first press conference
for the last
16 presidents last week at the 50 day
mark
we got this stunning report president
biden blows off questions from reporters
as he goes 50 days without a formal
press conference
and then yesterday they announce
joe biden is going to do a press
conference
and now we get this discussion of
suspicion
katie i have to ask why in the world
would you announce a press conference
nine days from now um my theory is you
announce them that morning because the
press is going to come anyway who knows
what's going to happen in nine days
guys it's just suspicious why are they
announcing the press conference so far
in advance well what about the weeks of
reporting
about how biden is terrible because he's
not
announcing and doing a press conference
it's truly pathetic
they will never be happy don't try to
make them happy just don't waste your
breath
don't waste your energy and i actually
am looking forward to biden's press
conference
i look forward to him being asked tough
questions about the things we've been
asking about
the border and so many other things 15
what's the plan for the 15
minimum wage what's going on with
infrastructure do you plan to use budget
reconciliation to get infrastructure
done which we will talk about later on
in today's program
i'm very much looking forward to it we
don't have a schedule yet but it'll be
sometime next thursday
and you can bet that i will be live on
youtube
on twitch and on facebook in the
meantime
weigh in on this faux scandal about joe
biden's
press conferences by following us on
instagram at david pakman show
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
yesterday i played a news clip for you
from monday
in which republican house minority
leader kevin mccarthy staged
a propaganda photo op sort of event at
the u.s mexico border
and at this event he claimed without any
evidence that
turkish iranian and yemeni terrorist
undocumented immigrants were coming over
to the united states
by physically and illegally crossing the
mexico
land border with the u.s here is kevin
mccarthy
saying it as i played for you yesterday
let's review the clip
and when you go to monument 3 and you
talk to those agents
it's not just people from mexico or
honduras or el salvador
they're now fighting people from yemen
iran turkey
people on the on the terrorist watch
list they are catching and they're
rushing it all at once
now as i mentioned yesterday there is no
evidence of that but
it sounds really damn good and scary so
republicans have taken off with it and
this is quite literally what we mean by
memes it is a meme that has caught on
and yesterday on fox news republican
congressman john catko
um said the exact same thing and it is
spreading and it is becoming in the
absence of sort of like real
stories that fox news wants to
substantively cover
they are just grasping at straws as we
talked about yesterday
cancel culture dr seuss potato head uh
joe biden's
55 days without a press conference this
type of thing
now they're they've glommed on to this
take a listen to what catco
had to say addition to the migrants that
are crossing
um that there might be other bad actors
and possibly even
terrorists what did you hear from border
patrol yesterday
well it was a stunning revelation to be
honest with you we were at the edge of
where
new mexico mexico and texas meet and
it's called monument three we're sitting
up on a bluff
and we're asking the agents that they're
on the front lines and by the way there
is a big gap in the fence there
because of uh because of that they
stopped construction but
when i talked one of them was telling us
what they were seeing coming across the
border they saw over 100 people come
across in the last few days in that
one little sector and he said some of
them were on the list and i said list
and he said yeah the terror watch list
and i i was stunned
and i've never heard that before they
said they've seized not just people from
central and south america
but even people from yemen and places in
the middle east that are
terrorism hotbeds so the claim is
that people on the terrorist watch list
from the middle east or crossing the
land border between the u.s and mexico
now
is it possible that this could happen of
course yeah
it could happen it is conceivable that
a suspected known terrorist from iran
could get themselves to mexico and then
cross over the border you know in the
middle of the desert that that
could happen a friend of the show and
former
david pakman show guest congressman
ruben gallego
is on the subcommittee on intelligence
and special operations
he represents arizona a border state so
he would know something about this
and he tweeted quote weird as the
chairman
of the subcommittee on intelligence and
special operations
and a border state member of congress
haven't heard anything about this
going to ask for a briefing pretty sure
he is either wrong
or lying and the congressman went on to
say
hi republican leader meaning kevin
mccarthy i have the same security
clearance as you do
can you have your office arranged for a
classified briefing for members
to see where this info derived from
uh customs and border patrol was asked
about this
they haven't commented and the truth is
that this is just
an old lie that is being refreshed once
again
donald trump told this lie in 2019
donald trump told this lie in january of
this year before leaving office he said
quote we have terrorists
from the middle east coming into our
country through the southern border
and he also mentioned it last night at
the earlier in the show we covered this
very strange interview that donald trump
gave last night to
maria bartiromo and this was one of the
topics that came up donald trump again
made this claim
hey they're coming in you take a look
they're coming in from all foreign
countries i see they're coming in now
from yemen
they're coming in from the middle east
they're coming in from
everywhere they're dropping them off and
they're they're pouring into our country
if it's happening it should be dealt
with and taken seriously but there is
still no evidence that
people on the terrorist watch list from
iran
yemen and turkey are going to mexico
and then illegally crossing over to the
united states now if you're going to say
well david
if they're doing it illegally we don't
know we can't we we can't say for sure
we don't know that it's happening but we
can't say that it's not
well that's an indefeasible statement
that that would be as
as plausible as me saying you know there
are people from
australia going to argentina renting a
motorcycle and driving all the way north
and then riding the motorcycle uh
through the desert
you you can't say it's not happening
well then what are we talking about here
at some point we have to say what is the
evidence that this is going on
so this was actually floating around
during the obama years and it's
important to remember
just as one data point that the saudis
who did 911
came to the united states legally with
visas
they took flight lessons at american
flight schools
you know all of this different stuff why
smuggle yourself
in through the southern border why even
send people already on the watch list
which could only attract attention it
makes no sense
it doesn't even pass the sniff test and
i
actually am wondering has there been any
terrorist attacker
on u.s soil who came from the middle
east
over the u.s mexico border illegally i i
looked i spent some time this morning
looking
i wasn't able to find a single example
of
any uh wrongdoer i guess is the the term
assailant i don't know what term you
want to apply who did what is being
alleged here not a single example and i
by all means
if you find one let me know and i will
issue an update
a correction call it what you will but
yet another
completely imagined story which as of
yet is not supported by
any evidence whatsoever so this is
really funny this is another example
of controversy where there actually
isn't any controversy
fox news ran an explosive
headline yesterday called democratic
senator
caught on hot mic explaining
how dems will fast-track infrastructure
uh-oh
what happened what sort of devious
tactic or plan do democrats have
to get infrastructure done this is
all about democratic senator ben cardin
ben cardin
was speaking to transportation secretary
pete budej
about joe biden's infrastructure plan
and ben cardin was
caught it was a hot mic guys he had no
idea he was being recorded
he was caught saying democrats
will use budget reconciliation
to get infrastructure reform done
requiring only a simple majority in the
senate
instead of 60 votes yeah now you might
say
hold on a second sir david we've
expected democrats to have to do that
all along
because republicans are and have been
and will continue to be total
obstructionists there will
there will be no way to get
infrastructure done without using budget
reconciliation
what why is this news that ben cardin is
saying this and that is exactly the
right reaction if that is your reaction
ben cardin was caught on a hot mic
saying something that we already knew
and expected and which bernie sanders
actually
said publicly here's the big explosive
hot mic moment take a listen
but ultimately similar to how
you're good okay so there's ben cardin
saying hey pete we're going to have to
do this like the coveted relief bill
via budget reconciliation where's the
scandal
like what choice do democrats have when
republicans won't vote
for anything at all and in fact bernie
sanders
the funniest part is you don't have to
have a hot mic
bernie said this on february 24th it's
public record
axios reported on february 24th that
quote
senator bernie sanders told axios on
tuesday he's consulted with the white
house
about how to prepare for the next round
of spending and he's ready to do it
immediately
via reconciliation a process he controls
as chair of the senate budget committee
there is no story here okay
joe biden said he wants to do
infrastructure
got it we desperately need to do
infrastructure spending
okay infrastructure spending is popular
with the american people
good donald trump also promised to do
infrastructure endlessly and he never
did it
so it's overdue and fox news is
reporting as some kind of
scandal what the obvious
publicly acknowledged strategy is going
to be
on getting infrastructure spending done
which ben cardin
said to transportation his uh
transportation secretary pete
butterjudge
that given republicans plan to keep
obstructing
we are going to have to do it via budget
reconciliation this
scandal is arguably less controversial
even than when barack obama wore a tan
suit and i would even go as far as to
say and some of you may disagree
this is less of a scandal than when
barack obama asked for brown mustard on
a hamburger
i'm i'm actually willing to go out and
say it is it is less
explosive even than that so we've talked
about this we did a we talked about this
yesterday
there's two different things going on
number one joe biden is really boring
that's true and it's a welcome change in
many ways
the press briefings aside from the sort
of weird questions
from fox news reporters the press
briefings with jen saki
are boring from a sort of salacious
entertainment sense but they are
substantive and the right
absolutely hates this because there's
just no scandals
so they're manufacturing things ben
cardin caught on a hot mic
joe biden hasn't done a press conference
for 55 days i actually
this is even funnier this morning fox
apparently
now that joe biden has announced a press
conference for next week
fox news had to up their ante so this
morning i saw
a a graphic which was something like
joe biden hasn't done a press conference
for 89 days
if you include the 2020 campaign before
he was even president
mr potato head kermit the frog
pepe le pew speedy gonzalez you know all
this
this is what they are now focused on
because they don't know what to do
absent scandal when the things that joe
biden has done so far
primarily at the top of the list the 1.9
trillion dollar coveted relief bill
are popular even with republicans to a
great degree
i would expect more of this although my
my prediction would be
fox newsmax and oan us are sort of going
to find their lanes
right now they're kind of fumbling
around in the dark for like what's the
way we can get the most clicks
based on this administration i think
they'll figure it out and they'll settle
into something probably within the next
few months
the david pakman show is audience
supported media
and you can contribute any amount you
want on patreon as little as
one dollar per month plus you can get
the daily bonus show world famous at
this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
show picking up where i sort of left off
in the last segment uh i mentioned that
joe
joe biden has been very boring for
right-wing media he just sort of is
trying to do the things he promised he's
not succeeding on all of them he's
succeeding on some he's failing on
others he's mostly liked by americans he
successfully did covet stimulus he's the
most popular
president based on initial approval
rating of the last
nearly 30 years and things are just sort
of like going
okay there's no major scandal uh he even
said
you know the one of the new narratives
has been why isn't joe biden saying
something definitive about the
allegations against
andrew cuomo he said last night in his
interview with george stephanopoulos if
the allegations against cuomo are true
then he should resign
up so the right really has no idea what
to do so they're fabricating scandals
one such scandal has been the crisis at
the border
which we discussed earlier and we're
going to keep talking about
but before we get to that they are also
going and going and going
on so-called cancel culture now we've
been covering
like once or twice a week just kind of a
tracker
of how fox news has now uh done three
i don't know if we're on week three or
even into week four
on dr seuss which has been a big topic
of obsession for fox news
and it's become daily programming on a
variety of right-wing network
right-wing networks including fox news
check out some of these delusional
clips here is someone named jillian
turner
who's a fox news correspondent trying to
make some kind of impassioned
speech about this up ahead
plus cancel culture is spreading like
wildfire there is now a call for
generation
x that is x to lead the charge to save
america from the social
media mob can they do it
cancel culture spreading like wildfire
what is she
talking about and on screen during that
clip
was an image of if you saw it
mr potato head dr seuss
speedy gonzalez pepe le pew kermit the
frog
and miss piggy characters clearly
of foremost importance to the fox news
audience as you can imagine
there's also as i've said before
something really funny
about the fox news audience supposedly
being all worked up about
literature when a lot of these people
haven't read a book in their lives or
since they were last forced to maybe
when they were little kids
there is some irony there for sure
here's another one
big dramatic teleprompter read about
cancel culture this one during this one
on screen you will see
mr potato head again speedy gonzales and
pepe le pew
and a few dr seuss book covers latest
apparent victim of the canceled culture
that saw dr seuss's books pulled from
the shelves
mr potato head losing his gender and
social media critics saying some looney
tune characters are no longer welcome
this is what it really looks like to
have nothing to talk about now
i don't even know so we've talked about
the potato head thing
we've talked about dr seuss i have no
idea
about the controversy involving speedy
gonzalez and pepe le pew
my guess is that there
are some people who believe that speedy
gonzales
uh plays on tropes about hispanics
and that pepe le pew plays on tropes
about
french people and and smelling i don't
know like i'm
i'm guessing that somewhere someone said
something like that and now fox news
says that it's a cancel culture element
and what's really nuts is that there may
even have been
more total coverage of this
than of the january 6th riots as they
actually happened
by trump supporters like certainly fox
news has covered the riots
but in a way that doesn't really tell
the story as it is which is a bunch of
trumpists inspired by trump
uh trespassed and uh committed acts of
violence and
and uh vandalism um then more culture
war stuff
fox news running stories for 36 hours
about the grammys
including one story with the headline
grammy ratings take
massive hit this is something they've
been doing for years when the
oscars come around they say record low
ratings for the oscars and as i've said
before
that kind of makes sense to me um
television audiences are more fractured
than ever
and the importance of these sort of live
events and one time events
the more alternatives there are the more
diminished the importance of any one
event is i haven't watched the oscars or
the grammys in a decade i don't care
about it
but again fox news's motivation is
always to sort of gin up these culture
war elements and then of course
any time that there is either an
election coming up we saw this leading
up to 2018
we saw it again leading up to 2020. if
there's an election coming up
or there's a democratic president in the
white house
you can count on right-wing media
talking about
immigrant caravans coming to the border
that democrats don't care about fox
also running a headline about this
yesterday saying
signs of new caravans
heading to the border
they apparently realized that they can't
really get away with
caravans at the southern border
so they're going with the softer
headline there are
signs of caravans
heading to the southern border
so like you know maybe in southern
mexico they're noticing some people who
are
packing up food or something like that
then lastly
every single day every single day and we
talked about this earlier so i won't
dwell on it but it's part of the bigger
story
they've been talking about how joe biden
hasn't done a press conference yesterday
it was
55 days without a press conference the
day before it was
54. for weeks it's been where are the
press conferences
and now that joe biden announced the
press conference
for next thursday they went on yesterday
about
it's suspicious that he's announcing it
so far ahead of time so we won't rehash
that
so there's two sides to this on the one
hand
this stuff really doesn't seem to be
affecting joe biden's approval
it's in the very high like 59 to 63 it's
been in that range and it's remaining in
that range
and i know it does you know to a lot of
people that won't sound very high
if you understand the range of
presidential approval if you understand
hyper partisanship if you recall that
donald trump not even for one day
reached 50 approval it it actually is
quite notable
so the the fake scandals don't seem to
be hurting biden
on the other hand what happens when
there is something closer to an actual
biden scandal and there there well may
we
may be one at some point you know so far
there hasn't been but
there could be will they have cried wolf
so much that the real biden scandal
won't be taken any more seriously
than you know dr seuss or whatever the
case may be i don't know the answer
but we're going to continue following it
david horowitz
is a radical right winger who in my mind
is most notable
for once telling dave rubin in an
interview that barack obama was a
communist
and this came up during my interview
with dave rubin years ago which i'll
play for you in a little bit
now since then i've not even heard the
name david horowitz mentioned but he
resurfaced yesterday
on right-wing propaganda network newsmax
to say that the who the world health
organization
is also a communist organization run by
a quote terrorist let's dig into it and
there's there's actually
this allows me to tell you some things
about what's going on at the who let's
take a look at the first clip
you know is this do you think part and
parcel of their whole program here you
say it's just about control is it really
just about control
the chinese communists whom the
democrats defended during the virus
who one of biden's first acts was to
give them half a billion dollars to that
communist organization who the world
health organization it's run by an
actual terrorist
um that's the the first thing that they
did
was to blame blame trump for
using the word china virus
we know the president has a hammer over
him because of the
criminal activities of his son nancy
pelosi has huge investments in china
she's protecting eric swalwell who not
only slept with the chinese
communist spy but allowed her to build
his
his political career he sits on the
intelligence committee
these are incredibly disturbing facts
about the democratic party
we know david that if if if biden's not
going to talk about hong kong and taiwan
with china those things are off the
table
this isn't going to come up in this
meeting either we'll have to leave it
there for now great to see as always
dave we're out of time up against a
commercial break
so david horowitz is now 82 years old
and his one line is the same one as it
was when he was 72
and when he was 62 anyone he doesn't
like
is a communist and just about everything
that david horowitz said there is false
remember that eric swalwell handled the
chinese spy situation 100
correctly eric swalwell was notified by
authorities
this woman you had a relationship with
what we believe is was
is slash was a chinese spy and he
immediately
turned over all the information he had
cooperated fully
and he's not even been accused of any
wrongdoing so horowitz mentions eric
swalwell
the interview isn't even really about
eric swalwell that's just like an aside
here is david horowitz years ago saying
that barack obama is also a communist
this is just his go-to
this is this is why i say barack obama
is a communist
he was raised by communists he's his
whole political career until he became
the united states senator
was in the communist left uh i mean i
know these people
if you are part of a movement that you
know is evil
the first thing you want to do is warn
other people about it especially when
it's so deceptive
it talks about social justice and all
this crap anyway
no well i mean but he hasn't so that's
how you know what his allegiances are
and so of course barack obama is not a
communist and
back then i actually asked dave rubin
about this
when i said to dave rubin you know
sometimes you don't push back when
people say crazy things and he said well
what's an example of that
and i cited that exact interview with
david horowitz
and here's how it went with dave rubin
now when david horowitz in this
specific instance when he said that
communist thing i was
in that particular case i was about to
stop him but you're right he then did
quickly he like sort of said it
it was right at the top of the interview
he kind of flew right into something
else
and then and then the conversation just
went from there i do remember thinking
in the interview that i wanted to get
back to it but
in the course of an hour conversation i
think that one was almost an hour and 20
minutes
uh you know sometimes something's gonna
get lost the hilarious part
is that horowitz didn't go right into
something else as dave rubin says dave
horowitz and
david horowitz in fact sort of like
paused
and dave rubin could have asked him
about
well what in what ways is barack obama a
communist
it was reuben who chose to move on so
david horowitz is known
for calling anything he doesn't like
communism
and anybody he doesn't like a communist
and interestingly
nobody seems interested in confronting
david horowitz about it now i don't know
if they're intimidated by him or they
like
people being called communists i don't
know at one point david
horowitz was actually considered by some
on the right a conservative intellectual
if you can imagine that
now to be thorough horowitz also claims
in the newsmax clip that the who
is run by a terrorist there there
actually is
some story to tell you about there the
who is run by
ted roast adenom tedros adenom i hope
i'm pronouncing that correctly
who's an ethiopian biologist
the allegation has been made
that tedros when he was one of the
officials in control of the ethiopian
security services
from 2013 to 2015 um
was the allegations range from
indifferent to all the way up to
involved in sanctioning
the killing and torturing of ethiopians
that took place
now this is an allegation that a few
people have made
some of whom have uh sort of
questionable questionable credibility
and and um questionable motives as well
the allegations haven't determined
anything
i'm glad for it to be investigated but
to casually call ted rose
a terrorist absent anything other than
an allegation
seems to be a bit much but they don't
care this is what they do
so david horowitz using a very common
right-wing trope that that it seems to
actually pull well because it's repeated
so often by right-wingers
anybody you don't like is a communist
and we saw how effective it was
leading up to the 2020 elections we saw
how frequently you would just go you
know our friend michael shore would go
to trump rallies and interview people
and they had the vocabulary they had the
language they very quickly would go
to biden's a communist biden's a
socialist and
we know that it sticks and maybe that's
why david horowitz loves it so much
we have a voicemail number which you can
call if you have anything to tell me and
many of you do
that number is 219 to david p
here is a question about vaccine
distribution
and the chinese coronavirus vaccine
let's listen
hey david many places like the
philippines fielder being left out to
die by americans
because they say that america's holding
vaccines and so many countries are
actually turning to cenovak the vaccine
from china
what are your thoughts on the sentiment
of being abandoned
secondly can we really trust the
cindelbach vaccine approved by the ccp
considering what the ccp doing is doing
to uighurs to bends hong kong etc
yeah so there's two questions there
first of all
the hoarding of vaccines by certain
countries i mean listen yeah
it's going on uh it's completely
predictable
and at least internally logical that if
you are the government of the united
states
you would first try to get enough
vaccines for the united states
the counter argument that's being made
is the u.s has secured way more vaccines
than the u.s actually needs for 330
million people that's true
the us doesn't have nearly all of those
vaccines and and some of those
contracts i believe are sort of
backstops uh you know securing 100
million extra doses of the jnj vaccine
in case pfizer and or moderna don't come
through the u.s has already said
anything extra we're going to start
giving to other countries so
this is a tough situation because
countries are going to try to vaccinate
their own people first that that makes
perfect sense the question becomes
when there's disproportionate market
power um when there are dramatically
different financial situations
um at what point is the behavior
considered predatory and
that's sort of an ongoing debate now the
question about can we trust the chinese
vaccine
i mean listen i don't know the the who
is going to decide whether to approve it
the chinese vaccine from from sinovac
xenovac synovac is a conventional
vaccine rather than an mrna
it has the advantage that it can be
stored in a standard fridge instead of
requiring a particularly cold
fridge the efficacy is unclear
the data we have so far from trials in
turkey and indonesia
the turkey trial says it's 91 percent
effective the indonesia trial says it's
65 percent effective that's pretty
different
is it because of different variance
strains
it's just not clear yet researchers in
brazil said the chinese vaccine is 78
effective but then they revised the data
and said oh it's only 50
effective i i don't know and i have no
special opinion about it
you know the the sputnik vaccine uh
didn't go through
nearly as as rigorous uh testing before
approval that it was approved in russia
before
being as extensively tested with
completed
stage three phase three trials as in the
us
but from what we know now it does appear
to be safe and effective by and large
so i i think the question is a perfectly
fair one
i think the answer needs to be guided by
the data
and we will see what the who decides now
there are some who will say the who is
so in bed with china and the ccp the
chinese communist
party that we can't even trust the who's
determination on this vaccine
i don't know i don't know i think it's a
fair question and we'll have
more data uh coming very very soon and
efficacy aside if we believe the early
data
it is like the other vaccines almost 100
effective at preventing
serious covid and death so we will see
what
the next couple of weeks bring on the
bonus show today we
are going to talk about the conflict
happening in some european countries
about the astrazeneca oxford vaccine
where some places have said we're
pausing this vaccine because of some
blood clots whereas others are saying
there is no evidence that the blood
clots are connected to the vaccine in
any way
we'll talk about that on today's bonus
show we will also talk about the the
governor of west virginia
um wants a population boom
in the state of west virginia and also
wants a disney theme park
and the plan is to cut taxes it's all
very weird we'll talk about west
virginia a state not often discussed on
the show
and we will also talk about russia's
forthcoming blockage of twitter
russia says they will block twitter uh
nationally in the country unless twitter
deletes banned content
and what are the implications what are
the motivations and we will talk about
that on today's bonus show how do you
get access
to the bonus show it's easy you go to
joinpakman.com and you sign up that's it
we have a coupon code the code is
better21 it'll save you some money
you're not obligated to use it but you
could be listening or watching today
listening to or watching today's bonus
show
in 60 seconds if you get a membership at
jointpakman.com otherwise i'll see you
back
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman